and I think once we get into this you're
gonna see the proof that Universal as
suspected are abusing the YouTube
copyright system
[Music]
has long been suspected that companies
on YouTube are abusing the copyright
system just to take down videos that
they don't really like doesn't matter if
they're fair use or not companies now
they can just fill in a form and within
an hour or so have a video completely
blocked everywhere Universal is a studio
that constantly do this and I'm sure
that there's hundreds of YouTubers
watching this who've been through a
similar sort of experience to what I'm
going to talk about the only difference
is we actually have an email from the
company that basically outlines that
this is indeed their policy now I was
talking to film speak about this the
other day a great YouTube channel he
actually did a video essay on Jurassic
world dominion and said lots of positive
things about it he was one of the only
people that actually liked the movie and
then out of the blue for some random
reason he got hit with a block video
pulled down he had to appeal it and then
it sort of led into a similar thing to
what I'm going to talk about now I've
obviously ran into this problem a number
of times before because we do deal with
a lot of spoilers whether you think
reviewers should be able to go see a
movie and then come home and talk about
what happens in it that is your opinion
you know some people are gonna say you
shouldn't ever do that and some people
will just say well you know these videos
are for people who've seen the movie
they want a more in-depth discussion
Beyond this was good I didn't like this
bit you know we try and take things up
to a different level where we analyze
themes in a film or talk about Easter
eggs or you know in the case of a Marvel
movie we'll we'll talk about how it
compares to the comics and where things
could be going in the future and it's
difficult to talk about those things if
you don't at least talk about the
elements of what's happening in the
movie A lot of Studios Embrace this but
for as bad as people say that Disney is
never ran into a problem with them
um talking about all of their movies
openly sometimes have said good things
sometimes I've said bad things and I
think they understand that word of mouth
around a film it gets conversation going
if you look at the the whole Ant-Man
condominia thing going on at the moment
you've got people saying the movie's
terrible you've got people saying it's
great it's the best thing ever and at
the heart of it is this discussion of
you know go see it for yourself you
decide which side of the camp you fall
on now M Night Shyamalan movies whether
you like them or not you have to admit
that they are interesting films at least
people want to talk about them people
want to hear other people talk about
them and that was very much why we
decided to cover knock at the cabin now
before we get to that I just want to
talk about exactly what fair use is and
what it's defined as so you can't just
take a movie and upload it to YouTube
you are breaking someone else's
copyright that is their work you are
taking it publishing it however if you
do say a six second clip from that movie
where you mute it talk about what the
themes in it are what's happening your
interpretation of it and also your
thoughts that's fair use now if you make
a video like that you're not just
re-uploading the movie you are talking
in depth about that film what you take
from it what your analysis is what you
see the ending as being and it's very
much a conversation with your commentary
that is your work for example say say
you're sat at the bus stop with your
friend you're talking about no way home
you're saying what's going on in it
you're getting your phone out you're
showing it oh look at this picture from
this bit
um a movie studio can't come along and
say you are not allowed to talk about
this it's very much the same case on
YouTube as long as you're adding
commentary discussion a review it's it's
covered under fair use basically if
you're making it into something new it's
something new you own it someone just
can't come along and take that away from
you but that's exactly what Universal
are doing now I asked Jared if he wanted
to cover knock at the cabin obviously M
Night movies like we've said very
interesting he thought he could get
something from it he went out stayed up
all night writing recording got up the
next day I think he had like two hours
sleep made the whole video spot on
uploaded it it did really really well it
was a really well made video very proud
of the guy for putting that together now
we've actually had issues in the past
where we've run into stuff and for
example he did the same thing on
Halloween ends he went out
um I handed the job over to him I went
out for like the first time in about six
months with my friends because obviously
we just had kids I was out got
notification at 1am so saying your video
has been blocked no reason why it was
completely Fair review of Halloween ends
um and I just rushed home trunkly made
another edit it wasn't very wasn't very
good uploaded it and that was fine but
ever since then that's kind of stuck in
my mind so every time we've made one of
these movie reviews for a universal film
we've uploaded two copies of the channel
one's been private and one's being
public so if the public one gets blocked
which often happens with universal we
can instantly put the private one public
and that'll be fine we actually did that
with knock at the cabin
um and it was online for 10 days the
main video and I just deleted off the
other one because it was taken up room
in my dashboard anyway everything seems
great maybe Universal maybe they're not
going to be decks for once nope we're
putting the block the next day and
basically what that means is your video
can't be seen by anyone it's demonetized
um your Channel's kind of like oh we're
in trouble and all the money you've made
goes directly to Universal so those 10
days it was online that goes to them so
my company has lost money you know I've
got to pay charts wage years I've got to
pay editors myself
um all that money gone so it's like 10
days worth of money completely taken
away by Universal now because it's fair
use I instantly disputed it however
because this was a stricter block and
that block remains in place of 48 hours
and Universal have seven days to
basically say yes or no this you know
what this is fair use ought to be like
no no this is the movie they've just
re-uploaded it this is our you haven't
transformed it in any way now those 48
hours that's just a policy YouTube has
in place I don't think it's right I
think once you dispute the video
um especially if you've got quite a good
standing where you make nothing but fair
use videos I think that should go online
instantly again but you know 48 Hours
um that that's blocked and it basically
gives Universal say that amount of time
to put something together gets to the
47th hour just about to go live
Universal come in go actually you know
know what he has stolen our content so
it gets blocked again for another 24
hours and that deadline of the five days
gets pushed to another seven absolutely
ridiculous and unfortunately the way
YouTube works is you are guilty until
proven innocent if someone claims your
video they say it's theirs don't have to
provide any proof just say yeah that's
mine um it's not fair use the video gets
taken down so what comes next well I get
a couple of options I can delete the
video
um lose all the money from it goes to
Universal uh but that's it I lose so
Jared's wasted his time completely
um we've lost all the money we're just
we we could have been doing something
more productive which is why we tend to
cover more Disney and Warner Brothers
stuff because Universal suck if I don't
do that which I won't because it's a
fair use video I will get a copyright
strike and then I'll have to go through
another appeals process to get that
taken away the video will be blocked
again I'll have to fill in the form
YouTube's copyright team and then have
to review that normally takes about five
days then they decide whether the video
can go back online again which sucks
very stressful because as many of you
know if you get three strikes your
channel gets deleted so I lose my job
Jared loses his job editors Matt and
Steve they lose their jobs got families
to support
um you know I'm clearing out my house
I'm moving at the moment got a mortgage
lots of stress because someone in an
office somewhere has just decided to do
this for the sake of doing it so this is
the first time I've ever done it spoke
to someone legally who contacted
Universal now I'm gonna read out what
that email is
um I've blocked out their name because I
don't want this specific person getting
in trouble but this is the response and
yeah it just backs it up that Universal
of purposely doing this purposely
targeting people even though it goes
against fair use so basically my rep is
like yeah I work with an outlet called
heavy spoilers this video has been
blocked blah blah blah the person
replies hi Mo just jumping in here can
we check what time of material slash
content was within the heavy spoilers
piece that might lead to a copyright
flag guessing it means type of material
we would need to look into it further
for you we have where possible try to
limit the amount of spoilers mentioned
in pieces and particularly for an M9
film we want to maintain the secrecy and
entry even if the film is out we do
Endeavor to keep things as fresh for
audiences as possible so completely
understand your point and promotion but
just giving an overview of things from
our side so they are openly admitting
there that they will block videos
doesn't matter they will just block them
if they decide that they want to keep it
that way now you might be thinking
that's fair enough for an M Night movie
but again that is your opinion on the
matter that's not the law that's not
what things Say on YouTube the terms of
services you cannot flag a fair use
video and if you do you are abusing the
system I went back to split and that was
released on the 20th of January guess
who put out a spoiler podcast on the
23rd with happy side confused was M
Night Shyamalan spoiling his own movie
three days after our video had been over
10 days and then it gets flagged so it's
just it's the company basically
enforcing and being like uh you know
what we're going to intimidate this guy
into deleting this video we don't care
that he's worked on it you know Jared
spent ages doing it poor Jared
um and it's just getting ready
ridiculous Universe I'll do this all the
time there's so many other Studios I
mean Disney Gets such a bad rep and you
know the reason why there's so many
negative videos about Disney on YouTube
is because they don't really care and
will let people discuss the company
because they're not going to go after
people and the fact that there's so many
of those online shows that they're not
abusing the system to take videos down
might be bootlegging a bit did just give
Quantum Mania a bad review some might be
trying to get back in the good books but
yeah Universal uh so many YouTubers out
there are gonna have similar stories to
what I've got
um the only difference is they've never
had a statement back from the person
working PR I think that shows that they
are basically admitting that you know
what yeah we actually want to keep
things secret even after release I
haven't signed anything never agreed to
do that never went to a private
screening Jared didn't go to a private
screening never sign an embargo thing
never broke never broken BOGO never
signed an NDA a saying you wouldn't talk
about this stuff how are we supposed to
know this how are we supposed I mean
there's so many times that I've done a
spoiler video for a universal film
nothing's happened but because there's
some policy inside of their PR where
they want to keep things secret and
Intrigue I've got to waste my time doing
it we wouldn't have made the video If
that had been clear from the start and
it wasn't because they're just 10 days
later they're clearly they've looked at
the box office for the film it's about
to go on streaming and they clearly know
crap we've kind of uh we've kind of shot
ourselves in the foot with this release
it's not done as well as we want and
what can we do to get people to see it
and I will just there's a popular video
talking about the ending we'll just
block it and then hopefully people pay
for it on VOD it's absolutely ridiculous
it's such a bad way to go about it and
uh yeah I just I was so mad seeing that
email because it's them just making up
the rules for themselves this is not in
place on YouTube
um the website article there's no way
they can take that down because I on the
website YouTube It's a completely
different system now you can say what
they want and Universal they keep on
doing this having it in black and white
like that written in an email you know
it just it really annoys me because it's
something I've suspected for a while and
I think Universal I'll just stick heads
for doing it now obviously this isn't
the CEO of universal doing it not
blaming him I I always think when this
happens that someone's just sat in an
office they've been hired to be you know
head of copyright on YouTube
um the boss will come in and be like
what have you done today Timmy what what
have you done today
you know that guy he's he doesn't want
to make it seem like he's done nothing
so he's been like had this video taken
down I've had this one he's just filing
false dmcas because you know this
there's no repercussions and it makes it
look like he's doing something might be
a woman might be being sexist but either
way they're just doing this harassing
creators stopping people talking about
their films and also putting their
channels in Jeopardy so from here on out
sick of universal I will cover their
films because I sudden I'm not going to
let this [__] in the office Timmy
spoil things for me but yeah it's
absolutely ridiculous and having it like
this it's really annoyed me
um so yeah if you went through a similar
sort of thing let me know below I don't
want to be putting out this video you
know I'm in the middle of moving house
and this is just extra stress that I
don't need
um so yeah I hope we'll share this about
if you've had a similar experience I'm
sure many of you have
um hopefully we get the video back
online very soon but yeah that that's it
and uh thanks for sitting through this
big rant don't really like doing it very
negative but
that's that's the position that this
this movie studio put me in many be
entertaining people and he'd put me in
this you goddamn summer [__] but I
hope Disney's watching this as well
because said lots of nice things about
him get me back out there thanks
[Music]
foreign